you'll see Saturday I'm excited about
that are we gonna wash that together I
don't think so why not me you Grillo
Jeff Foley illicit huh my butt go we'll
go to Frank you know I don't like to
watch play through this no but we're not
gonna say anything it's Tony Ferguson
just engag I can't I can't believe God's
the greatest art of all I can't believe
Dominick Cruz is fighting say who - I
had no idea I can't [ __ ] believe that
that's gonna be [ __ ] Francis and
Donald versus roses stroke is
unbelievable Stephens kid is
unbelievable
Greg Hardy Castro's fun Cerrone pattern
is on the prelim why is that on feelin
well leaked to the rest of the mankind
where would you put your impetus in
other words they don't they don't there
were long in the tooth
so they date so Jeremy Stephens Trump's
Donald Cerrone and Alvin kadar does
because he's import he's awesome belt
yeah he's [ __ ] very impressive
Peniston cowboy
they're both longing to mmm Calvin kadar
wins that one he's up there dude you
talk about real contenders up there
Hardy yeah that's the Castro that's it
but also yeah remember they always put a
big two big names on the main event of
the prelims so you get excited and
bright it's a [ __ ] great there are
two that oh boy I'll hold that for a big
pay-per-view on the prelims when I
fought Lavar Johnson uh-huh I'm very
happy with that prelim card you will yes
Roni Pettis ver doom Olynyk has Cerrone
Pettis they haven't fought before how
they have today 13 Pettis beat him in
Broomfield Colorado body shot close
right
Carlos Carlos noxious far as far as that
Michelle Waterson you're at Hall Jacare
and then the before even all that the
Cente Luke Davis Nico price should be
that could be other I wish they were on
the main card they should open up the
main coach Charles Rosa hasn't fought
for a long time I feel bright mitral
that's the fun one Sam Sam up Alvey all
these are great great fights yeah man I
can't wait
Rodin's doing it Grogan John Anna candy
see the a-teams going out there well
I'll watch it together it's not
happening
you're gonna stay on the card Wow it's
too big of a card to get a focus what do
you mean you gotta focus I can't have
you guys you know you know hugging again
you're Frank the body shop no get your
hands up Oh God we trained nothing worse
I trained I can't dude I'm as
well-trained with Brian filaria who goes
you have good fundamentals and I want I
want you guys handle oh yeah there you
go
hate so the thing is is I'd rather watch
your Buffalo Wild Wings than with you
guys what [ __ ] is going on here I just
like to watch in peace man I like just
experience at all look at that
[ __ ] right there four-time world
champion y4y or yeah and hope you know
and everybody should see that guy cuz he
couldn't be thicker and and it's so
apparent he could knock me out so
quickly it's just so funny
he doesn't seem 5'4 but he is but he's
like that one to our next game he's
Hawaiian no Filipino but born in Hawaii
yeah really good guy man really [ __ ]
good guy really interesting even buy him
more for the fights station maybe I will
look at him I'd hang out Jeff
yeah Jeff is such a great guy hey Jeff
Foley shout out to Jeff Foley boy
Freddie Roach is officially short yeah
pretty short Wow every one of those guys
give me some trouble in the ring I think
have you pretty sure you'd be pretty
healthy yeah great good the rest of it
guys don't walk in the Filipino gyms
going who wants to bang who wants to
know I walk in and go Manny Pacquiao
suck see what happens you guys want to
come up and Manny you suck yeah now you
see the the precautions yes he's taken
and ones crying how can they do this
event during Corona if she's going
through the [ __ ] wing or just to get
it down you guys know everybody's
getting tested multiple times we get a
fight they digger their own individual
training rooms the winner of the fight
goes into secluded
like area to take interviews it's what
is this man I mean I just on the for the
record I disagree with it before
entering but then when they get back
before entering the hotel room and
athletes temperature will be taken I'm
feeling if they found someone they're
just not gonna say anything I don't give
a flying [ __ ] if every athlete on the
card got Corona all of them would be
just fine
they're not gonna say anything first I
don't care I've got to cancel I don't
clearly know that I cancel anything and
I don't care hey don't know what listen
the guy putting the event on is the only
one who should be worried if he gets
Curran a Dana White cuz his online
health condition I'll make it down make
a call right now you ready for my call I
don't know you seem to enrage maybe go
ahead well I rewatched the Mike Lee 21st
and fight a couple things after watching
that I watched Mike leave hold on after
watch that fight I'm a-goin Richardson I
want to make those heavyweights yeah I
believe I believe number one when khabib
does fight Tony Ferguson whenever
doesn't matter here's get to he wins
khabib wins I put all my money I could
be but I'm gonna tell you what was what
else Tony got taken down a ton in that
fight and got hit a lot and does get hit
a lot and his his advantage is he's very
good I'm obviously amazing has crazy win
doesn't get tired in the world best card
in the world but great jujitsu if he
tries to stand and bang with just engage
he and Justins wrestling is better oh no
aah then Tony oh that's right Tony was a
wrestler to know I'm Jim I think if he
he was hmm the you know it doesn't
matter no one's gonna wrestle
if anybody wrestling yeah Tony Justin
doesn't wrestle but it's a very
dangerous fight for Tony I think it's a
more dealers it's a more dangerous fight
than could be for Tony because just well
what's like it to me it's like you know
Tony was plan to go scuba dive in the
deep ocean yeah and he was ready in
mine was said to school dive in deep
water and go deep with kabhi yeah and we
know exactly where getting deep what you
didn't get into when you go deep-sea
scuba diving yeah and there you go
change of plans you're snorkeling and
it's in hurricane water who's gonna be
choppy but and what if you can get past
the current then you're fine right but
that Kurtz a [ __ ] yes it kills a
lot of people yes but you gotta get by
that current
yes back Tony will meet you halfway and
they start holding will get head Tony
Tony got hit in the micro John site
idiots Pettis got hit against Valerio
yes you know so there's a lot of yes
a lot of guys he does get hit now if you
get hit by just engaging you don't get
up he has me it's a such a dangerous
fight for Tony if you like dogs get gay
choose the dog there's a ton of dogs on
this fight card you can make some money
there's a parlay you can make and we
should do it I think you put $100 you
can win 15,000 and the chance of these
underdogs and winning are pretty [ __ ]
good I'll do it all right let's do it
let's do it huh batad bet for us okay
good let's do it now let me ask you this
does gage he does he gas I camera I
haven't seen him gasps he's tired he
does get tired night cuz she cried she
has about 18 minutes of pure [ __ ]
round yeah and it's tough to deal with
it's possible and Tony gets it yeah it
to me it's a more exciting and more
dangerous fight than Tony kabhi kabhi
he's that he's not gonna submit Tony
he's not gonna pound Tony out the only
way that fight is a finish if Tony
submit some more cuts him up and doctor
stoppage and Tony wins detail or it goes
decision Tony what is just as ranking
for this right was there anybody else
you would have liked to see no fight
this is the perfect fight Walt Conor
McGregor obviously Conor McGregor I
think I think Connors gonna fight Maas
with all yep for me oh my god I can't
take that fight
come on Armand off does that wake your
trouser snake oh my god maybe more than
anything oh you like that oh my god
maybe more than anything well because
there's always two of the best strikers
in that division like well here's that
with your beta or Dana
cuz you Sosa fight komaru semen for the
title yeah i'm dana goes no we have
something bigger so what would be bigger
than Camaros man for the title has to be
Connor Oh
you ready for this old man or Nick Nick
Diaz with-with-with no s-70 Nick with
with Cosmo defending his brothers honor
I love its storyline - I love it I love
Nick Diaz been so long I just think it's
no Moz well [ __ ] would beat them but I'm
just saying it's a when you talk about
bigger fights for his views or its
Conner Nick right surely think if
something bigger than fighting for the
title I would just love to see Moscow
Conner I'd love to see them try to slug
that out that's how [ __ ] why don't
think of the buildup [ __ ] [ __ ] AFL
titles Christ yeah man yeah [ __ ] and
look when asked about Mozilla
potentially defend the bfb MFL title BMF
title sorry give me a thorough nail in
there
B M F title against the tourists on
fight island white added very good point
that's possibility the Asiana wants to
find on that fight Island Moscow all its
final fight Island what's bigger than
mozzarella find it 70 does he have
trouble with 55 because I'm a fifty yeah
he achieved Moz via all fight Tony first
and also would be you not getting that
for a while though but we're talking
about something in the next you know two
months a month or two whoa
you know no matter what happens that gay
Qi Tony fight they're not both those
guys get [ __ ] up so you're not seeing
them for a while yeah
so it has I think Connor Moslems what's
gonna set June or late June and and when
and when Mazda all was on my show on
food truck Diaries his manager and him
we're like Connors the fight that's all
we wanted to converse that's all they
want I bet I bet I wouldn't you deserves
money is that's where the big money is
god damn I want put some bets down all
right yeah that partly would be fun yeah
it's crazy it's like 100 pays 15,000 and
you look at the fight you like [ __ ]
those odds are pretty good now for all
that to happen the parlay if one guy
loses in a weird decision because it's
MMA you get [ __ ] I don't like parlay
is parlays so if we if we bet five
fighters and they're all dogs all five
have to win no work for you get your
money if if four out of the five win you
don't get paid that's a better underdog
so know what to make this much money you
do but they're good bets decent earth I
like Castro over Hardy as a dog
crews as the dogs good gauging the
dominant crews gives it to any victim
decision
what yep you don't say but K but K
trousers but game we give me another how
do you say why in um
zom zom well it's a Korean Zombie I
don't know greens very easy it's where
where where where yeah I think time
accrues beats of the other system Jesus
that's that's you know else thinks that
Kenny Florian what I haven't been him
did a breakdown yesterday Oh somebody
shred it out that's mines great is he
fighting it not 25 is 35 yes
who's that guy go back
that's a mustache [ __ ] hey is that me on
trt yeah but he's much shorter than you
Baba but he's a nudist ID yeah there's a
thick fellow so who is a absolute
ultimate winner everything medalists I
mean he's just the shoe division wait
chances astonish and I still think crews
beat some decision unless you're not
crews out he's a vegan hit though Mighty
Mouse he's because BJ do it Chris did
but certain say who dough right yep if
you beat them but you know I think I'm
gonna guilty by oh dude dan wait legend
the only reason I idol a of it but the
only thing it's not just lay out when I
saw what Karthik Odegard Brian did to
him boxing wise I I think to myself he
was the one who set and and he didn't
expect that out of in if you hear him
talk about that phasic I haven't use any
counter punch we weren't ready for the
ha oh you say you threw me off okay I
made some changes so we'll see alright
McDonough Cruz you said his genius is is
the best smartest
smart MS MMA strands the Elon Musk yo
fighting yeah he's the Elon Musk Jesus
oh why cuz he sells footwork seminars on
his Instagram let's go get us but work
if I take it does you should take him I
will well do you think I'm kidding
you know how that's I tell you do it
yeah I'll [ __ ] buy that right now are
you doing it for free
I'm 40 no you can buy is it free when is
TJ back I don't know but he seen me up
[ __ ] when he comes back it's
gonna be a he's part of the the thick
boys bike club is he uh-huh he's awesome
here's a white tee by love TJ and what's
not to love about that guy two years and
that was last year so yeah did you have
one more year April 2009 teen yo April
221 welcome back all right
not too far well EP on everybody I'll
show you my hand caught it right now
those cameras you got two years a wolf
or be sort of Doom's fighting this
weekend he got two years - oh he got
less time off - because of that you know
snitching cause what he told on I don't
know I'd loved he was come on food-truck
diary oh I wonder if it'd tell me a man
who just a child
yeah from leniency some time off at his
age you like do what I'm telling these
guys to probably aren't even the UFC or
if you toll on the supplier like a ball
Co situation I get your money dude ah I
can't I do I I'm so proud of UFC men I'm
so proud of you [ __ ] fan the UFC me
too and the event they're putting on
this weekend I want everybody to buy it
I love it
buy it don't [ __ ] pirate it like me I
mean like these other people don't make
me shut down your stream I'll be buying
it 100% I'll be buying it I've seen the
promo no you guys want to watch it
section three minutes though is this for
the USA yeah for them coming back
oh yeah chills eight different dudes I
like look at that whoa oh my the best
highlight is awesome you say I'm gonna
kick your ass
get emotional I have unbelievable right
I have a boner Oh unbelievable Jesus
Christ it's unbelievable
wow what a great promo little bail
sucker both thumbs hey Brennan I'm not
watching me come back with like in also
seven-year layoff yeah he's been a comic
got a fat cast boy I got a lot of that
[ __ ] about and me behind you like you're
coming against Greg Hardy Greg Hardy and
I'm just massaging your shoulders
and I'm wearing a loincloth we don't
know why he's back he's back and Brian
Callens in his corner and you just see
me doing this
against all odds yeah it's gonna be good
right now [ __ ] back kick
use your backhand back flip back to
about do a back flip
boy oh boy that's gonna be so exciting
we have to watch that together oh no I'm
saying just come nope no no because come
see Frank grow a star and a me check for
I love you I love Frank I love the [ __ ]
out of Jeff nope see that see the bunch
of other people can't believe a bunch of
other people it's Corona maybe some
people but not a lot maybe nope
give me some kind of ends just sure he's
gonna Charlie you guys watching it
hell yeah I don't know how I'm gonna
watch it I bet you would be me you Jeff
hey Randy give each other no absolutely
not
maybe a couple of people are you
watching cat um
maybe probably we're you know watch it
kid I was playing do a zoom watch all my
friends but then zooms like 40 minute
limit or something like that
also that's I know but still also hey
I'll help you it's also that's gay I
mean gay not as in I have sex with the
guys but no no no like it's like but you
know what the slang gay or just FaceTime
then Oh
google hangout has something where you
guys can share screens Oh God look
daddy's gonna jack off together be in
the same rooms enough I'll tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]